So if you were to give guidance about
where to put all these fancy read
listeners in your activity,
what would you say?
>> You know, that's a great question and
I'm not entirely sure.
>> Eh, it was mostly rhetorical.
I've actually done a little
reading on this one.
Here's what I found.
Here's our friendly Android life cycle,
where we create and
destroy our Fire base listeners
is a typical developer trade off.
Memory versus network
traffic in this case.
Remember that every time you recreate
a listener, it pings the database.
And listeners are also so big they
can be kept around for a long time,
in which case they leave
a memory footprint.
So, there are some different rules
of thumb that you should go by
when you're actually creating or
destroying your listeners.
If you're going to come back to the
activity a few times, you should make
your listeners in on create, and
get rid of them in on destroy.
This is because your activity
will be going in and
out of the visible life cycle, and
therefore on start and on stop, and
on resume and on pause will get called
many times as your activity lives.
You put your listeners in any of these
methods, you'll be generating unwanted
network activity by continually
recreating listeners.
If the activity is likely to be a one
off activity, you should consider making
your listeners in on start, and
cleaning them up in on stop.
So you might be wondering what
I mean by one off activity.
Well, some sort of activity that
the user is unlikely to return to.
Such as a login screen.
A user will probably log in once and
then sort of use the app for a while.
They might even minimize the app and
do other things and
come back to the app, all without
visiting the login screen again.
Now why not just put these in
on created and on destroy?
Well, on stop will be fired sometimes
significantly earlier than on
destroy will.
And because of that you'll end
up freeing up the memory sooner.
With all of that said, the engineers
at Fire base did build listeners to be
relatively lightweight, but
just like cleaning up your listeners,
this is another best practice to
keep your app running smoothly.